in this video you're gonna learn how to
solve systems of linear equations in two
variables using the substitution method
we're going to go through two examples
and the first thing you want to do is
you want to look at your variables and
you want to solve for one of the
variables you don't want to find out
what x equals or what y equals once you
know what that quantity equals you can
put it in the other equation to get one
equation with one variable so I'll show
you in the first example the first
example is a little bit easier because
you see how we know what x equals we
already have X by itself x equals 4 plus
y all we have to do is put that in place
of X and we're gonna get one equation
it just has y's in it
now notice when I did that substitution
I put instead of X I put what x equals 4
plus y but you want to put it in
parenthesis you want to treat it as a
group now we just have one variable
we're gonna go ahead and solve for y so
that gives us 8 plus 2y minus y equals 7
2y minus y is 1 y bring down the 8
subtract 8 from both sides of the
equation and you can see that Y is equal
to negative 1 now you can take the
negative 1 and you can put it back in
for this Y or this Y either one it
doesn't matter you're gonna get the same
answer when you solve for X but this
one's gonna be a little bit easier since
we already have X by itself so let's go
ahead and put negative 1 in 4 y 4 plus
negative 1 is 3 so now we know x equals
3 and we can write this as a coordinate
pair 3 comma negative 1 so what this
means is if we were to graph these two
lines the point where they intersect is
going to be 3 negative 1
okay example number 2 is a little bit
more challenging because it wasn't like
this one where we already knew what one
of the variables equaled we have x
equals over here you have to decide
should I solve for this X and find out
what x equals or should I solve for this
Y and find out what y equals or this X
or this Y well in this particular
problem it's going to be easier to solve
for this Y because you only have one Y
so you won't have to divide so all we're
going to do is we're just going to
subtract 3x from both sides of the
equation so now we get y equals negative
1 minus 3x and so that was for the
second equation so now we know what Y
let's go ahead and put it in for Y in
the equation that we haven't used yet
the first equation so we have 5x + 2 x
now instead of Y I'm going to put y
equals negative 1 - 3 x equals negative
1 and again remember when you do that
substitution put it in parenthesis so
you can treat it as a group so now what
we want to do is want to distribute the
two and that's going to give us negative
2 - 6 X bring down the 5x combine like
terms 5x and negative 6x is negative 1x
add 2 to both sides and we get negative
1 X is equal to 1
divide both sides by negative 1 and you
can see x equals negative 1 now if we
take negative 1 we can put it back in
for X here or here or here I'm going to
do this one because we already have Y by
itself so we're gonna put negative 1
right back in there
so that's going to give us y equals
negative 1 minus 3 times negative 1
negative 3 times negative 1 is positive
3 and so then Y is equal to 2 and so we
write our final answer we want to write
it as a coordinate pair X comma Y or in
this case negative 1 comma 2 now if you
want to check your answer you can always
put negative 1 + 2 + 4 x + y and see if
it equals negative 1 same thing here
make sure it equals this value make sure
it makes both equations true now the
next thing you want to learn is how to
solve systems using the elimination
method follow me over to that video
right there where we dive into
elimination